a good citizen
you know this year we did something a
little bit different we established a
website called WWI is the show so long
calm and we received about 35,000 jokes
and these are the best three the first
one these are these are real jokes these
are these are from fans all across the
country we got we got letters from you
know email from Norway Finland China
every place so this one is from our lang
which is why is the show so long because
they're just so many little people it's
cute
there's a website jokes folks
the next one comes from Jay Phillips
which was what was Bill Clinton's
favorite movie last year 101 donations
it's not bad Steve you know and last one
comes from D snow quote it comes out of
my mouth you know I expect to win an
Oscar next year I'm making a movie
called prices very sexy and Waterhouse
is a genius
not bad so thank you America for sending
these in and speaking of Price
Waterhouse Wow
there is a gentleman from the firm who
was retiring after 21 years of servicing
Oscar that sounds terrible
he is and I mean that
21 years he's being replaced and let's
bring him out right now Blaise and
gentlemen Frank Johnson 21 years
when when you're his Frank Johnson
Frank just say best picture and we can
eat
Frank is being replaced by Jim and Susan
mcdougal from MTV to their own hit movie
these animated characters or what
happens when Sylvester the cat and
Tweety Bird make it with Leopold and
Loeb here are the bad boys of MTV beavis
and butthead
we're movie stars
well good sound effects editing can make
the difference between a boring chick
movie with some English dude and a
really cool movie with lots of
explosions and stuff yeah like under
feet - for example when I smack Beavis
sound effects create the illusion of
pain I really get hurt the nominees for
best sound effects editing are Richard L
Anderson and David a Whitaker for
daylight Alan Robert Murray and Bob
asmin for eraser Bruce Stambler for the
ghost and the darkness and the Oscar
goes to whoa Hey Bruce Stambler for the
ghost in the darkness
Oh God thank you for the academy
director Steven Hopkins Michael Douglas
Steven ruther the entire sound editing
team at sound storm
everyone's great there I couldn't Owen
be here without him Don Mitchell Frank
Montaigne Rick Hart Mike Hrbek and Peter
McGregor Scott Dennis burglar Joel
Schumacher Carol Don toño
for their continual support my family
nan Kelly and Robbie thank you